- Yes!
(audience clapping and cheering)
We're very excited.
- Yeah.
- It's nice to meet you.
And they're still going.
(audience continues cheering)
- [Christina] I guess we
got some Yellowjackets fans.
- Do you get this all the time?
- No, not really. I wish.
- Everywhere you go.
- I wish every time I walked
into a room that happened.
- Very excited. I will look
into making that happen for you.
We were just talking about snacks.
I've heard that you keep a fortune cookie.
Is, this true? Like a fortune
in your phone at all times?
- Yeah, I mean, I sort
of have lost the meaning
a little bit like a long
time ago I was like,
I got a fortune and I was
like, oh I hope this one
comes true so I...
- Held onto it?
- Yes. I had a clear
phone case and I was like
well, I'll just put it
in the clear phone case.
And then I got another
one and I was like, oh
I'll put that one in there too.
And then something
happened where I lost them
but I just kind of kept
putting new ones in.
But then recently on an
airplane, a man used it
as a way to start a conversation with me.
So I feel like I have to
stop doing that because.
- Yeah.
- I don't need that much attention.
- On an airplane in general you just wanna
put your headphones on immediately,
and just, yeah.
Because a lot of us, it's not
that we're trying to be rude.
- No.
- It's just that I have
kids, y'all, I'm never alone.
- Yeah.
- I don't want talk to you.
It's not because I'm trying to be mean
I just don't wanna talk.
- Yeah.
- Like, it's just like, you
just want your, you're like
oh my God, this is the this is
the time, this is my me time.
- Yes. Yeah. A hundred percent.
- I get you.
Maybe stop carrying things
that start conversations.
- Yeah. I know.
I'm gonna, I'm taking it out.
It was removed.
- Well, I actually, I
love fortune cookies.
Me and my eight-year-old
daughter love them.
We're obsessed with them.
So do you want to open some
new fortune cookies together?
- Yeah, yes.
- [Kelly] See what we get?
Okay.
(audience cheering)
- Do you do the rule where
you have to eat it first and,
- Oh my God, I thought you
were gonna say the rule,
that's not a children appropriate, but no.
- Oh no. I don't know that one. At all.
- No. You know, like
you put in the bedroom
at the end of every.
- Oh, not. I don't know that.
- What?
Like, you read it and then
it's like in the bedroom.
- Oh, yes, okay.
- Yes, yes, yes, yes, yes.
Okay, we're opening.
- My rule is you have to eat a little bit
of the cookie before you read it.
- [Kelly] Oh, okay. Okay.
- Otherwise it won't come to true.
- [Kelly] What if you
don't like the fortune?
- Well, that's just too bad.
(audience laughs)
- Okay.
- Mine says.
- [Kelly] Oh.
- Oh, mine's pretty good.
- Mine is too.
- "You will be the next
in line for a promotion".
(audience cheers).
- Congratulations.
- Yeah. I'm really excited.
- Congratulations.`
- Thanks so much, what's yours?
- Mine is "The only way to
have a friend is to be one".
- [Christina] Oh, that's good.
- I love that.
Be what you want.
Yeah. I might keep that in my phone.
- I'm actually gonna keep
this one in my phone.
- But don't talk to us about it.
- Yeah, exactly.
I don't care who talks
to me about this one.
I would like a promotion.
(audience clapping)
- So your new show Yellowjackets,
it's in season two.
So if people didn't catch
season one, explain a bit.
- Yes. The premise of
the show is that in 1996
a girl's soccer team goes off to nationals
and their chartered flight
crashes and they're stranded
in the wilderness and all kinds of,
trauma kind of, occurs afterwards.
You know, there's like a
supernatural element to it,
but you're not sure if that's just them
freaking out and seeing things or wether
this is really happening.
- Or if it's real, yeah.
- And then it sort of cuts in
between 1996 and them
stranded in the woods.
- Young.
- Yeah, they're 16.
- Like younger kids.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Around 15, 16.
And then to the older survivors.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- So, and that's present day.
So I'm one of the older survivors.
- Congratulations again.
- Yeah. I survived.
(audience cheers)
- So you've been acting
just since you were super
young. How young are you when you started?
- I started when I was seven.
- Geez. Like my daughter's eight.
- Yeah, my son is eight and
I always use it against him.
He'll say like, he can't,
he's like, he'll tell me
he can't do something
and I'll be like, well
I was working 12 hour days.
- You're that mom.
- Outside in the cold, when I
was a year younger than you.
(audience cheers)
So guess what? I know you can do it.
- Oh my God.
I love you're that parent
that's like, I walked to school,
uphill both ways.
- I really am. I am.
- I love that.
So wait, how do you, how do
you feel looking back on that?
Was that hard when you were a kid
or fun and you just kind of were in it?
- When I was a kid, it was so fun.
I loved it.
I really enjoyed escaping
from sort of my home life.
And I didn't like going to school and
I didn't like being a kid
and getting to go to set and
and be good at something
and to be encouraged.
- It feels good.
- Yeah. And to be successful at something.
And I liked the actual
day-to-day work and everything.
And it wasn't until I was
older and a teenager that
that I really kind of
felt the effects of fame.
And it was the fame
aspect that I didn't like.
- Yeah.
- I loved the work itself
but I didn't really enjoy all the
specific attention of fame.
- That can be hard.
- Yeah. And I think it's really hard too
when you don't even know who you are yet.
To be, have to ask
questions about who you are.
- [Kelly] As most teenagers. Yeah.
- Like how are you supposed
to present yourself
to the world when you
don't know who you are.
- And you're learning that.
- Yeah.
- I'm so glad I wasn't around
when social media was huge.
- Oh my God. Me too.
- [Kelly] When I was young.
- I was like a feral
creature as a teenager.
So it would've been a
real bad situation for me.
- Like all of us were odd, like right?
Or just figuring it out
and making mistakes.
- Yeah.
- Like not in the front
of the world. Yeah.
- No. I don't know how everybody
is handling it all so well.
- I know. My kids hate me.
I'm like, no phone. Sorry.
- No, I know.
That's a big thing with Freddy as well.
My son, he's so mad he can't have phone.
- His, my daughter's friends
have phones and I'm like
that's so great for them.
Congratulations.
- That's what Freddy says too.
Yeah. Freddy's like, whoever,
someone has a phone and I'm
I'm always like, well, you can't have one.
I'm so sorry.
- I'm like, who do you need to call?
- [Christina] Well,
that's the other thing.
- Who are you calling?
- That's the other thing too.
I'm like, but you have an iPad.
- That's what I said!
- And you don't make phone calls on it.
And you could.
- They hate being on the iPad.
They hate talking.
I'm like, what are you, it's not.
- So why do you need a phone?
- This is.
Yes.
- I don't know.
- And like, why are people giving
their eight year old's phones?
I'm not judging.
I'm just questioning. Why?
- And then, he was talking about someone
having a phone and I was
like, well, if you were
walking home from school, yes.
I might give you a phone for emergencies.
- [Kelly] That's what I said.
- And he's like, well, I'll
walk home from school then.
And I was like, you're not allowed
to walk home from school.
- He's like, weaving.
Yeah, that's my daughter.
So your husband does something nice
for you with memorabilia,
like from the past.
What is it? Can you explain?
- I have never saved
anything from my career.
Anything. Like, I don't
have my magazine covers when
I was younger.
I don't, I didn't save any of it.
And he thinks that
that's, he wants, he like
it's encouraging me to be
very proud of my career
and everything.
So he's gone back and bought,
found them all on eBay
and bought them for me and is like saving.
(audience awws)
I know, he's very, very sweet.
- It's kind of an amazing scrapbook too.
I always think now that as
a mom, like for your kids.
- [Christina] Yeah.
- That's the only reason
why I keep anything now.
Cause I'm like, they might
not care, but they might.
I don't know.
- Yeah, it's true.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- When I was little, I
really cared about my mom's.
My mom had, my mom was a
model and so she had her book
with all her tear sheets and
I really did care about that.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- So I get, I get his point.
- Yeah.
- But like, the kids wanting it and, and I
it also like is not, it's
nice and I think now that it's
most of those magazine
covers are like 20 years old.
And now that I'm 20
years from that person.
- It's like removed from it.
- I'm able to like be like,
oh yeah, that was great.
You know?
- Yeah. And you look, I always look
at things and people show me
and I'm just like, oh my God.
It was like a baby.
- Yeah. Exactly.
It feels like a different person.
- It really does.
I love age.